there were some elections last night
mostly primaries and we'll talk about
those later but an incredible if you
haven't been paying attention result
from last night is that Kansas voters
deep dark red Kansas voters have voted
to keep abortion legal in the state of
Kansas and the reason I say if you
haven't been paying attention it would
be shocking is that we know from public
opinion polls that now there is more
support for abortion being legal in most
cases in the United States than at any
point since the start of the Roe v Wade
era and so when the Supreme Court a few
weeks ago overturned Roe v Wade nine
people voted and six of them decided to
overturn Roe v Wade it is not
representative or reflective of the will
of the people of the United States we
now are seeing the proof of that in this
vote from Kansas the Associated Press
reporting Kansas voters resoundingly
protect their access to abortion
Reading Kansas voters sent a resounding
message about their desire to protect
abortion rights rejecting a ballot
measure in a conservative state with
deep ties to the anti-abortion movement
that would have allowed the
republican-controlled legislature to
tighten restrictions or ban abortion
outright this was the first test of
voter sentiment after the U.S Supreme
Court's decision in June which
overturned the constitutional right to
an abortion providing an unexpected
result with potential implications for
the coming midterm elections the
implications here are numerous first and
foremost oh uh the vote
um the by 20 points the vote was to keep
to reject the amendment which would have
allowed anything up to making abortion
illegal so a 20-point victory for the
pro-choice side in the deep dark red
state of Kansas now we've known for some
time
that Americans generally want abortion
to be legal now I know there are many
people who desperately want abortion to
be illegal but consider the
circumstances in the United States over
time the country has become more and
more in favor of legal abortion in most
cases and the country has become less
and less religious and we know that one
of the main groups that is against
abortion is those who are
religious a very particular kind we're
talking about Evangelical Christians
we're talking about Conservative
Catholics Etc that group has shrunk over
time there has been shrinkage and we
have seen support for abortion increase
now there are non-religious people who
are also against abortion no no problem
but the main opposition to abortion in
the United States is religiously based
so these are not surprising numbers the
connection to the November midterms
that's being made here is a very very
important one
tomorrow assuming everything goes right
things get a little crazy sometimes for
Rachel bidikoffer and sometimes
interviews get rescheduled but I'm
scheduled to speak with political
scientist Rachel bidikoff for tomorrow
the signs are increasingly pointing to
this year abortion rights and gun safety
being good issues for Democrats to run
on typically running on abortion rights
and gun safety regulations is not good
for Democrats if anything it doesn't do
anything to activate Democrats but it
does a lot to activate Republicans to
come out and vote against whoever is
supporting abortion rights and
supporting gun safety regulations the
polling we've seen so far already
suggested this year those might be
winning issues for Democrats the results
in Kansas
further suggest that that indeed might
be the case now you should be prepared
and it's already happening
for anti-choice Advocates right Wingers
kooky reactionaries all the normal
people that you would expect to come out
and say that the reason this vote went
the way it did in Kansas is for
something other than people just
generally want abortion to be available
in most cases doesn't mean you have to
get one or anybody in particular has to
get one but it's available as an option
for you and your doctors to determine is
the right one for you and they are
already going out of their way to say
this was about other things and I'm not
going to plague you with these examples
but here's one from Fox News where they
made it out to be basically the
pro-choice people bought these results
by spending a whole bunch of money it's
not reflective of the actual perspective
on abortion in the United States here's
one example Kansas referendum is very
interesting I do think that pro-lifers
should understand that so much money was
spent by hardcore abortion supporters to
make sure that that Amendment failed it
also was a pretty
um there's a lot that was packaged there
and I think that usually pro-life
initiatives do much better when they're
incremental and so it's a reminder also
that as Roe v Wade was overturned at
abortion law and policy is returned to
the States where people get to weigh in
there's a lot of work to be done for
people who want to protect women and
children from the scourge of abortion or
people who want to make sure that it is
enshrined in law so um so there's a lot
more to be done there and we'll see a
lot more in the years to come so that's
Molly Hemingway from the Federalist and
she's actually completely wrong it is
not about any of those things people are
less religious than ever people are more
in favor of abortion being legal in most
cases than ever the primary opposition
to abortion is on religious grounds and
they are just out of step with the will
of the American people that's what's
going on and listen it's Kansas if
Kansas is deep down actually against
abortion being legal you're not going to
be able to spend your way to a victory
the way that she's suggesting the
pro-choice movement would be able to do
there are people who want low taxes
low regulation to the extent that they
even I mean listen I'm being charitable
to the extent they even know what these
things mean you can be for uh low taxes
and low regulation and you know not
teaching transgender in schools even
whatever that means but still have come
around on the fact that abortion should
probably be legal in most cases and
that's what's going on so tomorrow
we'll talk to Rachel bidikoffer and get
her thoughts about what this potentially
means for the November election you know
um there are such things as coincidences
there really are I've had coincidences
where you know uh I'm on a flight and I
happen to be sitting next to Alex Jones
lawyer just after Alex Jones attacks me
that is a freaking Predator right there
okay like that's a coincidence I don't
believe that there's any larger message
for me to glean from being sat on a
plane next to Alex Jones lawyer it's
just a coincidence but then sometimes
you start to see coincidence after
coincidence and it starts to really not
seem like a coincidence and indeed it is
now hard to believe that there is
anything short of a concerted effort to
cover up elements of the January 6 Trump
Riot planning and Communications and
involvement of all sorts of different
parties in and around the Trump
Administration what am I I talking about
well here's the latest news
January 6th text messages
were wiped from phones of key Trump
Pentagon officials it is starting to be
very difficult to believe that these are
mere benign coincidences texts were
deleted they were transitioning to new
devices at exactly this time after being
told preserve the text messages the dod
wiped phones all of the same group of
people
and of of uh specifically at a time and
related to January 6th it's hard to
believe in this number of coincidences
let's look at what CNN reports the
defense department wiped the phones
wiped and flushed guys the phones of top
departing DOD and army officials at the
end of the Trump Administration deleting
any key texts from Key witnesses to
events surrounding the January January
6th attack on the U.S Capitol
the acknowledgment that the phones from
the Pentagon officials had been wiped
was first revealed in a foia lawsuit
American oversight brought against the
defense department and army
the Watchdog group seeks January 6
records from former acting Secretary of
Defense Chris Miller former Chief of
Staff cash Patel former Secretary of the
army Ryan McCarthy and other prominent
Pentagon officials Miller Patel and
McCarthy have all been viewed as crucial
Witnesses for understanding the
government response to the riots and
former president Trump's reaction all
three were involved in the defense
Department's response to sending
National Guard troops to the Capitol as
the riot was unfolding there is no
suggestion that the officials themselves
erased the records
oh boy oh boy
um everyone involved who committed a
crime should be in jail or prison I'm
not saying imprisoned people without due
process and without finding them guilty
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
they there should be no except
exemptions here because of people's
roles whether it be in DOD or wherever
the case may be
everyday criminals get in trouble all
the time for destroying evidence
white-collar criminals
uh often when it comes to tampering with
or destruction of evidence end up in a
situation where prosecutors go ah it's
really hard to prove that they acted
intentionally
going to be very difficult to prove
State of Mind here and yet we know it's
not that difficult because everyday
criminals Street criminals as they're
sometimes called uh get in trouble
regularly for these exact same things
and there are just too many coincidences
here to believe that this was not some
kind of concerted effort now you might
recall that days before what was
ultimately the final the last and final
January 6 Committee hearing there was
the idea that on a beautiful Tuesday the
house committee was going to get
recovered text messages from these
tranches of text messages that were
deleted and hours before the deadline
the Revelation was not recoverable not
going to get them sorry
and every aspect of this raises
questions as to in which organizations
were there
foot soldiers for lack of a better term
for the Trump Riot cover-up now we can't
say that secrets so part of this is
related to Secret Service here we're
talking about DOD
I'm not ready to say secret service was
involved but the longer it goes it
starts to get weird because on the one
hand we have Secret Service agents who
supposedly said in the aftermath of
Cassidy Hutchinson's devastating
testimony about what happened on January
6th we're willing to come in and testify
under oath about all the lies Cassidy
Hutchinson was telling and I said at the
time well great get them under oath but
then we'll have competing under oath
statements until then all we have is
nonsense and then they never testified
and the house committee was welcoming
them with open arms and they never
testified that starts to get a little
bit weird
then we hear well the text messages
involving the Secret Service also aren't
recoverable we can't give you anything
sorry
okay it starts to get a little weird now
we find out that the dod was wiping
phones starting to get even weirder so
I'm not pretending to have an answer I'm
not positing any particular allegation
of a conspiracy I'm merely saying
there's too many coincidences here to
believe that this is merely a
coincidence and there seem to be actors
in multiple organizations at multiple
agencies in multiple levels of this who
don't seem to be forthcoming in the way
that you would imagine and that you
would hope government officials would be
that's where I will leave it and the
speculation can sort of go from there if
you have an idea as to what you believe
took place here find me on Twitter at
dpacman and let me know who was involved
and to what extent
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David packman show is a community
viewer and audience supported program I
encourage you to sign up on my website
joinpakman.com we do lots of great
things for our members including a daily
bonus show now available in three ways
one on a website for members only two in
an RSS feed that you can put into any
podcasting app that you have or three
delivered to you hot off the presses via
email hours before the show is publicly
available to everybody else sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code obamna where's my Obama here oh my
goodness I don't even have it
nuclear proliferation that's not it okay
Obama
o-b-a-m-n-a is the coupon code that you
can use to get a discount off of the
cost of your membership do the thing
folks it's a beautiful thing there was a
delightful confrontation on Fox News
yesterday between Fox News anchor Harris
Faulkner and Democratic but very
right-leaning Senator Joe manchin now
the the thing going on with Joe manchin
is absolutely beautiful
Joe manchin is a guy that is not a
particular friend to the Democratic
party on many important issues but every
once in a while Joe manchin is a
Democrat and he will vote with the
Democratic majority and in this
particular case Joe manchin announced
that he's supporting the inflation
reduction act the inflation reduction
act does a whole bunch of different
things it doesn't change the level of
Taxation uh on income tax for Americans
but right-wingers have been flipping out
number one because they claim oh it's
going to increase taxes on everybody and
number two they're flipping out on Joe
manchin because they started to think
sorry I punched my mic they started to
think Mansion is a friend of Republicans
and to some degree he is but it's not
always the case and all of a sudden they
are hammering Joe manchin this interview
was absolutely hilarious Harris Faulkner
increasingly incensed with Joe manchin
let's look at some of the moments from
the this interview we got to know the
bottom line on taxes let me tell you the
bottom line on that hair so you want to
know the bottom line the joint committee
on taxation
that opinion was only written by my
friends on the Republican side it was
not done by the whole joint committee so
that is unfair too so let's be accurate
what we're doing here the bottom line is
how any world can you be raising taxes
when all we're saying is the wealthiest
corporations in America 55 of them pay
zero to help this great country of ours
to defend ourselves well how does this
change that because that that's that's
part of the minimum 15 structuring it's
a minimum of 15 the tax rate was at 35
percent before 2017. right then it went
to 21 that was a tremendous savings but
that's not good enough I guess all we're
saying is at 15 minimum everyone in West
Virginia I know and most people around
the country pay a 21 Corporate or
greater so why can't the greatest
billion dollars of Revenue a year why
can't they pay at least 15 percent for
this great country Now understand
they're talking about a 15
minimum tax on corporations but
Republicans are pretending that this is
an increase to personal income taxes
it's not
right because this is this is the part
that counts I'm
sorry to have complete departments
trying to come up with ways to to find
loopholes and and to keep and to hire
people as well I mean let's not forget
that too
um but four hundred thousand dollars was
supposed to be the cutoff and I'm
reading and I am reading Senator
any taxes who's paying any taxes that
doesn't have a corporation that has
revenue of over a billion dollars a year
not one person not one person Harris
you're assuming because they'll pass
that on the companies are paying zero no
no I'm asking a different question than
you're answering I'm saying Americans
four hundred thousand dollars and Below
now are going to be taxed their taxes
that is a pure outright lie now good I'm
not a fan of mansion you guys know I
don't see these people as black and
white
I don't get shocked all of a sudden when
Mansion says something reasonable or
then all of a sudden he's voting with
Republicans that we know who he is he's
a very right-leaning Democrat but here
he's doing a very good job taxes are not
going to go up not at all and you know
one thing how about the people that are
going to be saving as far as on their
Medicare 288 billion dollars who are
paying higher prices than he should
aren't they they didn't even assume that
in the revaluation they didn't talk
about any of that how about if gasoline
prices go down because we're producing
more oil to make more gas those are
going to fluctuate okay so Harris
Faulkner starts getting agitated to
different degrees and then eventually uh
Mansion just has to tell her that she's
telling lies I'm saying I'm saying
Americans four hundred thousand dollars
and Below now are going to be taxed
their taxes that's a lie that is a pure
outright lie so their taxes are not
going to go up not at all and you know
one thing how about the people that are
going to be saving as far as on their
Medicare too yeah so repeating that it
is just a flat out a lie uh then she
pulls up a uh segment of mansion
speaking to Chuck Todd and then tries to
hammer him on that and she increasingly
desperate during this conversation I
haven't
that wasn't dodgeball that's not a
dodgeball then I'm not getting involved
in the political this is not a political
piece of legislation this is an American
legislation we need energy we need to
pay down debt we need to accelerate our
our permitting process so we can build
things and meet the elections are going
to need some
helpful to make a statement is like as
low as congresses
when you get into the 30s no one's that
popular are you scared we're going to do
something good or help our country and
someone might take forever are you
kidding services in the Bible that's
what we do her father served and service
is in the Bible that's her reaction when
Mansion says Harris you sound mad we're
going to do something good and she goes
my father served and it's in the Bible
but how is that even an answer I know
how it's an answer because there's a
contingent and a lot of them watch Fox
News where they believe
if you are a veteran then of course you
know always necessarily want everything
that's best for the country there's no
guarantee of that and if you're a
Christian you always necessarily want
everything that's best for the country
but there's no guarantee of that either
serve our fellow man and woman that's
exactly what I'm doing don't don't make
this personal because it's not I'm
simply asking that you've got a
president who can't really help anybody
on the campaign trail with the numbers
he's rocking right now how do you say
something like that it doesn't sound
supportive of your own party and I'm
asking you just say this I'm working
with what I have here in the majority
party that we have as a Democratic party
I'm working with a president who's
accepted the proposal I've put forward
in negotiated which is a balanced energy
policy that's wonderful for our country
I know people who don't like the prison
or don't like Democrats might be upset
this is not about whether you like the
president or whether you like Democrats
do you like so as you can see Harris
Faulkner is just desperate to attack
whatever and whoever she can but the
truth is on this particular Bill Mansion
is correct the Bill's been scored it
looks like like it will reduce inflation
this is what the Republicans claim to
want to do and they just can't accept
that they just can't accept that here's
just one more quick clip that's a lie
that is a pure outright lie so their
taxes are not going to go up not at all
and you know one thing how about the
people that are going to and you know
what we already played this clip so
we're gonna skip it all right so bottom
line
depending on your perspective there are
people who now are angry with Joe
manchin and then there are people who
now are thrilled with Joe manchin the
reality is that there's sort of like a
grab your popcorn element to this
of wow what who's gonna flip out on
Mansion next and now it's Fox anchor
Harris Faulkner who's very triggered I
don't care about that so much as this is
another reminder
sometimes the these are just people
they're not all good they're not all bad
Mansion is a guy that is way to my right
but every once in a while and it could
be for self-centered reasons we don't
yet fully understand I mean it sounds
like there's going to be some more
domestic oil production Mansion likes
that yeah we could we it's potentially
just from his selfishness and what's in
it for me attitude that he's supporting
this bill but he's supporting a bill
that's going to do some good things and
it's going to it's believed that it will
lower inflation and now Republicans are
just absolutely flipping out on him
let's take a more measured approach this
is a guy who is to the right of me and
many in in the audience but he's doing
the right thing now and that's something
we can all be happy about we still don't
have many of the results from last
night's primaries and we don't yet have
the results for Kerry Lake a republican
running in Arizona but the new thing now
among Republicans is you just claim that
there's fraud even before the election
has started and that's exactly what
Carrie Lake did this video is from
Monday night on Monday night remember in
the United States we vote on Tuesday the
election was last night but on Monday
night Von Hilliard from MSNBC
confronted Arizona gubernatorial
Republican candidate Kerry Lake who is a
big Trump brown-noser and suck up
because she's already saying that there
is voter fraud and see if you can find
the list of things she does here that
expose her as an obvious Trump acolyte
take a listen you're already contending
that there's a regularity that there is
fraud in this election at what point
does Kerry Lake stop and say am I
undermining American faith in our
elections
but you haven't even laid out any fraud
or a regulars
[Music]
[Applause]
but what brought is there Gary what
fraud is there this is serious about you
no I and this is about Arizona voters in
their faith in this election
[Music]
so you know about a crime and yet you're
not appointing it to authorities
okay all right so let's look at the list
of things that Carrie Lake did there
that expose her as an obvious thrombus
number one she referred to herself in
the third person referring to herself as
Carrie like uh remember that Trump would
always say they want Trump they want
Trump he calls MSNBC msdnc that's
straight out of the Trump Playbook she
claims that there is voter fraud before
the election has actually been uh the
before the vote has been tallied before
elections uh the results have been
published That's a classic Trump thing
of course Trump famously doing that in
2020 in the lead up to the 2020 election
for about six months and then she claims
that there is a crime but she won't tell
us what the crime is and remember Trump
did that with Obama remember Obama gate
I don't even remember at this point what
Obama gate was even supposed to be
because Trump never told us and when
reporters would say there was one
reporter in the Press briefing room who
said what is Obama gate
and Trump angrily said you know what it
is but he never actually told us just
insisting it was the biggest crime of
the century or something like that so
apparently it's not just Democrats who
steal elections it's also other
Republicans in primaries I guess it's
non-trump Republicans now as of this
moment
Kerry lake is leading but has not won
her primary I would love it if Kerry
Lake lost her primary hold on a second
we're not even able to see this
accurately there we go Kerry Lake
currently with 80 percent reporting
Carey lake at 46 percent and the second
place candidate Karen Taylor Robson at
44 and remember this is the Republican
primary merely to determine who in
November will face Katie Hobbs Katie
Hobbs easily winning the Democratic
primary one thing uh that you will
notice is that
um more people voted in the Republican
primary than the Democratic there in
Arizona and we will see what that
suggests might happen in November but at
least for now it would be an absolute
Delight if Carrie Lake ends up losing
she is ahead by about 12 about 11 000
and a half votes right now with one out
of five votes still to be counted but
there's already voter fraud now if she
wins what will she say about voter fraud
will she say there was none of course
not if she wins she will say there was
voter fraud just not enough to steal the
election from me that's the deal and
we'll have that clip of Carrie Lake
speaking to Von Hilliard on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show I told you
a few days ago that I have not been uh
paying enough attention to this Alex
Jones defamation trial it's actually a
really big deal because it is going to
ultimately test the limits of what can
people with audiences and the
responsibilities that come with those
audiences myself included what are we
allowed to say about just individual
private people before we are liable for
defamation and that is exactly what is
that issue here this is a trial
happening in Texas Alex Jones is being
sued by parents of victims of the Sandy
Hook school shooting yes the one from a
decade ago and the trial is completely
unhinged Alex Jones seems to have almost
like a cartoon lawyer who I I actually
wonder if it's a strategy because the
lawyer is trying to cause a mistrial
that's one aspect of this and we have
video from Alex Jones testimony over the
last couple of days it is wacky now we
are going to start
uh in this first clip okay the ju Alex
Jones appears to be chewing something
during the course of the day's events
and the judge Maya Gamble
tells Alex Jones to stop chewing it and
then Alex Jones starts opening his mouth
and says that it's gauze and she's like
you're chewing on gauze and he doesn't
really say that it's every moment of
this trial is bizarre take a look at
this
it goes on and uh
he says to be sorry and we'd ask that
the entire house
what is it
because you're not allowed food or gum
of any kind anymore
I have my tooth pulled a week and a half
ago and it's I had some laws earlier and
it's it's been causing me to have some
pain so you're chewing on your gauze
would you like me to show you so it's
not really clear he says he has he had
gauze in there earlier
no I just want you to answer my
questions
hole sit down
every every so it's it's endlessly funny
but the problem is
what can she do she could eventually say
there's a mistrial but it seems like
that's only particularly good for Jones
because it just delays judgment
um here's another moment
in which they play a video of Alex Jones
saying that the plaintiff dad seems
autistic and again the whole thing just
goes completely and totally off the
rails
please
I thought it was an act but I saw
something oh and I'm sorry what's
relevant here is Alex Jones is doing
this stuff during the trial and so not
literally during the trial but I mean in
breaks and on days where he doesn't have
to be in court and so his discussions of
the trial are coming up during the trial
more and more because the judge is not
happy that he's talking so much about
the trial
yeah
what you say he's he's a he's an ice fan
and
he's not an accident he is
um being manipulated by some very bad
people
but I'll just says I gotta be honest
he's slow okay
and
his ex-wife is not I don't think he's
stupid I'm just saying he's he's
I've got family members that are really
smart in a lot of ways but they're just
real kind of quiet and have this way
about other men and and they they move
in different pace like they're fast in
some ways and slowing others and he's
I mean I can cancel and actually
somebody on the Spectrum and I said
before I could eat a bigger jerk
well I saw there's something about this
guy this doesn't look and now that I've
been around him for over a week I'm like
okay
now I know it's a folks I don't have
some calculated point just bringing that
up here it's just that I'm around these
people and I'm looking at it and I'm
watching what's being said and what's
going on and it really then
makes it clear what happened so Alex
Jones during the trial doing doing
coverage during which he says that it
seems as though the plaintiff dad is on
the autism spectrum then here is some of
Alex Jones actual testimony and it just
goes he just can't stick to the
questions that are asked it goes
completely off the rails again
thing else before we bring the jewelry
back
all right we're ready to have the jury
back
oh and this may not even be the exact
moment that I wanted to okay Alex Jones
sworn in okay so he's he brings up a
piece of paper and he's immediately told
you can't have notes and then the first
question he's asked he just goes on a
rant so if you were here when I
explained to a prior witness who brought
documents with them that you can't look
at any document for any reason why
you're testifying is going unless one of
the lawyers or myself instructs you to
do so so I'm going to ask you to
actually just give it back to Mr Reynold
until he may think you need it okay your
God
did you understand all that I did
yesterday okay while you testify it is
not a conversation it is a question and
answer so the instructions aren't to let
the lawyers completely finish asking
different questions so he's told you you
have to just answer the question that's
asked and then look at how quickly that
doesn't happen
all right
Alex would you please introduce yourself
to the ladies and gentlemen hi I'm Alex
Jones
how are you feeling today Alex
I actually feel good because I got a
chance to for the first time
say what's really going on instead of
the corporate media and high-powered law
firms manipulating what I actually did
I want to
um
start by kind of letting the jury know a
little bit about your Youth and where
you grew up so they can get to know you
better is that okay okay and you know
before we do that I just do want to say
this under here because I've said it
many times I apologize to both sustain
so Mr Jones one of the instructions I
just gave you is that this is not a
conversation question and answer so she
got the monologue about me I got it and
so argumentative with the judge yeah and
and again this all could be a strategy
to try to get a mistrial to make the
plaintiffs have to start over you have
to
to certain all the questions you want
you have to wait for the question
you may receive
okay so then at another point during
this the topic of Alex Jones gravelly
voice comes up you guys know that
gravelly voice globalished
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike Obama Trudeau macron okay that
that's me actually so now let's get to
the actual subject matter of his voice
and then again the plaintiff's attorney
is like is there is is and there's is
there any relevance to this
so one of the things I noticed uh about
you is that you have a very
very
distinctive
voice
very deep sort of gravelly voice did
your voice always sound that way no what
what happened to your voice why does it
sound the way it does
well I remember the two demonstrations
were finally erected
and one was about
I guess about
12 13 years ago it was actually a film
of it
oh I'm sorry go ahead
do you have something to tie this to
anything related to this case
[Music]
right the jury could not possibly
understand who the client is unless the
back story on his gravelly voice is
explained
um one more really interesting moment
there are
two assertions that the judge tells Alex
Jones this is outside the audience of
the jury that he can't say Alex Jones
refused to participate to allow
Discovery in this trial and we covered
that meaning he refused to allow the
plaintiffs to gather all of the things
that they he was in order to allow and
he says during his testimony that he
allowed Discovery in addition he claims
that he is bankrupt but that's not
actually true he filed for bankruptcy
and the judge tells him you can't keep
saying that stuff
you may not say to this jury
that you comply with discovery
that is not true you may not say it
again
you may not tell this jury that you are
bankrupt that is also not true
you may have filed for bankruptcy
I don't know that but I've heard that it
doesn't put it doesn't make a person or
a company bankrupt
so um again
she is completely correct about all of
these things but what's the recourse is
it to declare a mistrial and if so
everything I'm reading is that actually
helps Alex Jones and it hurts the
plaintiff so a completely insane trial
and uh on on an upcoming live stream we
may or may not talk about it more let me
know your thoughts hey here's some good
news and we've been looking for good
news lately in a new poll John fetterman
the Democratic candidate in
Pennsylvania's Senate race is ahead of
Mehmet Oz the television doctor by 11
points this genuinely is good news if Oz
were able to defeat fetterman it would
be a disaster now there's still some
disaster in here but we'll talk about
that in a second Democratic candidate
John fetterman is leading Mehmet Oz by
11 points that's a Fox News poll
the poor and remember Fox News polls are
not particularly bad polls
um the poll released Thursday found
fetterman is backed by 47 percent of
Voters Oz is backed by 36 percent so
it's an 11 point lead now it's still
horrible that an out-of-state television
grifter can get 36 support at the same
time I think about 36 percent of the
country at least 36 percent of the
country believes the Earth is only 6 000
years old so it's maybe not that
shocking but the important thing here is
let's not assume that this is over this
is a critical absolutely critical Senate
race if you break down there's a bunch
of different scenarios that you can
outline
um but most importantly
if you say which one race could control
of the Senate hinge on there's like a
handful of such races and
um one of them is the Pennsylvania
Senate race so if you're from in the
state of Pennsylvania you must vote you
must vote we all must vote and if you're
from outside the state of Pennsylvania
you're still allowed to phone bank
you're still allowed to donate or Lobby
for donations fundraise whatever uh very
very important race and again we don't
we don't concede races just for the hell
of it but given some obscure race in a
extremely red district for Congress and
this Senate race when we think about the
potential consequences this Senate race
is pretty pretty high on the list so an
important one to get involved in we're
going to continue covering it 11 point
lead is good A lot can happen in the
next three months and it is now only
three months until those midterms and
we'll continue covering this one
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
there's a really interesting kind of
reef shuffling I guess we would call it
a right-wing media I'm not going to
spend a ton of time on this today and
those of you who have been watching
listening to recent episodes you already
know about this it's not actually
happening but there's a growing
narrative that Fox News has abandoned
Donald Trump now the reality is much
more measured it's not that fox has
abandoned Trump and it's not that fox is
completely brown-nosing Trump there's
sort of a spectrum on Fox news but Fox
News is doing the best possible thing
for their business with their news
coverage now the nighttime opinion
people are still sucking up to Trump as
much as they ever were even to some
degree the Fox and Friends people are as
well but Fox News is setting itself up
to be able to kind of pull the Escape of
the uh um eject button and go to someone
else if indeed Trump is not the
Republican nominee in 2024 and maybe
there's even a slight preference for
someone else but regardless they're
still staying a uh keeping options open
I'm not wanting to lose access to Trump
Newsmax is playing up the war between
Trump and Fox News and of course they
would it's to their advantage if you are
targeting the most aggressively
sycophantic elements of the Fox News
audience they are the hardcore magats
and
um one of the things that might steer
them to your network is to convince them
that Fox News has abandoned your
president or whatever and so they're
really playing it up and they are
mentioning at any opportunity that it's
been a hundred days since Trump was on
Fox News and coming up Shadow band why
former president Trump hasn't appeared
on the major major News Network in over
100 days that's Fox News what's going on
there we discuss after the break that's
a very explosive story for Newsmax why
has it been a hundred days since uh
Trump appeared on Fox News it's all
self-serving and self interested that's
all it is yes Fox may have a slight
preference for someone else yes fox
wants to set itself up to have access to
whoever is the nominee in 2024 for the
Republicans but they're not actually
turning on Trump in any serious way then
they brought on some expert
um I don't even know who this guy is and
again the topic is about
um Trump and praising Newsmax and it's
the cup Newsmax is increasingly covering
Trump not being on Fox News if not ahead
um and and so it would seem they would
want to track this and he could announce
any day now now there's some people who
say he's not going to do that until
after midterms but we don't know that
and it defies common logic how do you
talk about the election for President
without talking about Donald Trump and
you think they're not talking about them
they're trying to avoid them I mean he
may appear sooner or later but they're
still going to try their best to ignore
him you know it's interesting because
you know
the thing at the bottom of the screen it
says Murdoch's move away from Trump to
be more establishment the idea being
that these are decisions being made not
necessarily by Rupert Murdoch personally
although maybe he's involved I believe I
don't remember which of Rupert Murdoch's
kids there's like uh Lachlan Murdoch and
all these different I don't I don't know
which one of them is highly involved at
Fox News right now one of them is
they're framing it as a personal thing I
think that this primarily continues to
be a business and access thing but but
we'll learn more about that I'm sure as
we get beyond the midterm for Newsmax
what what you are so happy that we do as
as I know many of our viewers are as I
am as well that we let our viewers
decide and we present them with the
information and okay if you agree great
if you don't you don't but even former
president Trump has lauded Newsmax
certainly has and for good reason we we
give him that that vehicle to at least
speak to what he speaks to and again let
our viewers decide I mean you know we
have an intelligent viewership as I
thought the times in the post did too
but now that's not true I I would guess
we're finding out differently well it's
interesting that the New York Times of
all people are the ones that come out
and say you know what
oh my God yeah Brian Anderson normally
it's us telling obvious lies but every
once in a while the New York Times will
come out and say something so that's
what's going on Newsmax coverage is
increasingly covering Trump not being
covered by Fox News in as favorable
terms as maybe they would like to see
and again these are all business ploys
Disney everybody wants to chalk this up
and this is sometimes what I'll meet
people
from outside the media space like most
people I meet are outside the media
space even though because of the space
I'm in I know a lot of media people as
well the people in the media space get
it
but then I'll talk to people outside the
media space and they will understandably
believe all these narratives Fox News
has taken this perspective for moral
reasons and then Newsmax has this other
belief in reaction whatever yet to some
degree that goes on but most of these
networks and channels it's not like the
David Pacman show where it's just
there's no posturing it's just my
opinion that's it if there's a story I'm
not interested in I just don't cover it
if there's a story I'm interested in I
cover it and I just give you my opinion
there's no posturing it might be good
for quote clicks or it might be bad for
clicks with Fox News and Newsmax and
whatever it's all being primarily uh
analyzed through the lens of what does
this do for our viewership and Fox News
right now has made the calculation
probably a correct one that they need to
find kind of straddle the fact that
there is a negative uh there's a
rappelling going on by some come in the
right wing of trump and Trump might not
be the nominee in 2024 he might not even
run
and so they need to be ready for that to
credibly be able to rejoin the
establishment for lack of a better term
but they also need to keep the door open
for Trump that's their calculation it's
nothing about ideology although there
might be ideology that's part of it
Newsmax I guess they probably do love
Trump but I'm sure there are people who
work at Newsmax who are kind of see
Trump as a buffoon but their calculation
is playing up the war between Trump and
Fox News is good for our viewership and
it's good for our positioning and it
might ingratiate us with Trump even
further so that he will appear on the
network more talk about us more Etc
that's what's going on don't don't think
it's anything else we have now learned
that Donald Trump had the opportunity to
go after Al-Qaeda terrorist I'm in
al-zawahiri when he was president
Joe Biden recently making the decision
to strike al-zawahiri killing him
but Donald Trump chose not to do it
because he didn't recognize the name
these are now the widespread reports
Business Insider Trump had the chance to
kill Al qaeda's leader but didn't
because he didn't recognize the name
the al-Qaeda leader Iman al-zawahiri was
killed by a U.S drone strike Biden
announced Monday then president Trump
had the option to kill al-zawahiri but
chose not to NBC reported in 2020. Trump
wanted to kill Osama Bin Laden's son
instead because it was the only name he
knew
can you imagine
um intelligence officials briefed Trump
many times about senior terrorist
figures that the CIA wanted to track
down and kill mentioning al-zawahiri two
people familiar with the briefings told
NBC that Trump chose not to pursue
al-zawahiri because he didn't recognize
his name he instead said let's go after
Hamza Bin Laden he would say I've never
heard of any of these people what about
Hamza bin Laden a pentagon official told
the news outlet that was the only name
he knew
the Department of Defense and a
spokesperson for Trump did not
immediately respond to Insider's request
for comment even though Bin Laden's son
was widely seen as an emerging figure in
the terrorist group he was not believed
to be planning any attacks at the time
the president's preference for a
celebrity targeted killing
um not surprising and listen bottom line
Trump didn't perceive that there was
anything in it for him
and Trump probably rightly assessed I I
think this is almost certainly true if
Trump doesn't recognize the name he
assumes a lot of his followers don't
either that that's probably accurate but
also understand that Trump could make a
big deal out of whatever you know he can
come out and say you know who we got we
got JP Al's no I'm sorry I'm an
al-zawahiri we got him and this guy was
a big deal bad guy uh I sometimes would
call him Abdul as he often says during
his speeches and it and his followers
would have said look he got JPL zawahiri
or whatever the guy's name is I think
that that probably would work but to
some degree there's this what's in it
for me and killing someone whose name is
Bin Laden is probably better this also
by the way
supports the reasoning for Trump
authorizing the Drone strike on the
Iranian General better headlines it
might incite Iran maybe it makes his
Saudi friends happy you know who knows
and sometimes you have to understand the
two filters one is is there something in
it for me which Trump asks the second
part then is Trump might not recognize
that there's something in it for him and
so if we think back to covid if Trump
had simply said masks are patriotic
we're printing 5 million exclusive Maga
masks only to be made available to my
best and biggest subscribers
um and then we're just going to follow
what doctors say he would have made big
money we know he makes big money off of
the Maga hats he would have gotten
reelected I mean it it really is that
simple and maybe we'll talk about that
tomorrow with political scientist Rachel
bidikoffer as well and by the way he
might have saved a hundred thousand or a
hundred and fifty thousand or even more
lives in so doing but Trump doesn't
always recognize when there's something
in it for him
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P a very good question
about monkeypox you know a lot of right
Wingers including Marjorie Taylor green
who we spoke about yesterday are framing
monkey pox as a gay disease they're sort
of talking about it like it's the new
AIDS or whatever and of course it's
merely coincidental that this initial
contagion group happened to be among gay
or bisexual men but it is already
spreading beyond that and this caller
asks a very good question
hey David Jeremy in Oregon here uh just
wanted to comment on this monkey pox
being a uh a homosexual disease what are
these conservatives that are saying this
gonna say when they come down with it
are they gay probably not and it'll be
dismissed and twisted into something
else yeah conspiracy we were infected by
George Soros or something no so here's
the deal
um at this point it seems like the
monkey pox cat is out of the proverbial
bag and we're already seeing people
other than gay men get it we're you know
gay men also have children and sometimes
they pick up their kids and so it's
obviously going to go bigger and
um the most like there's a couple
possibilities for how the right will
handle that one will be they'll say
okay like first it was from the covet
virus was from China but then thanks to
China it spread everywhere they'll go
with something similar they'll say gay
men seeded monkey pox in our communities
and now it's everywhere and it never
should have happened that's sort of one
possibility the other possibility is
yeah they'll just pretend they never
said the thing about it's a gay disease
they'll you know they're very
comfortable rewriting history
revisionist history that's a possibility
and the third one is yeah some other
conspiracy theory so they'll move on to
saying monkey pox is being shot with
some kind of Jewish gun by George Soros
or something like that
um something along those lines but
they'll come up with something else
whenever you think they won't be able to
talk their way out of this one because
the only explanation they could come up
with nobody would believe they come up
with an incredible explanation and their
followers believe it and they repeat it
so there's we've net we still have not
hit rock bottom that I can can assure
you we have a tremendous bonus show for
you today
top Democrats I'm sorry top economists
agree
the health care and climate package that
Democrats want to pass
will put downward pressure on inflation
Republicans should want it right right
and Idaho abortion law has now drawn a
Justice Department lawsuit we will
discuss why
and thirdly Joe Biden's task force has
indeed now reunited 400 migrant children
separated from their families under
Trump it's been done quietly it's been
done relatively efficiently although it
does take some time to do it and we will
talk about the implications and the next
steps on that on today's bonus show
don't miss the bonus show you can sign
up at joinpakman.com it's one of many
great membership benefits it now comes
with an upgraded experience thanks to
some new elements of technology that
we've implemented on the member podcast
sign up today use the coupon code big
voting22 to get a discount and I will
see you then
foreign